I'm Richard dog
my interest was rather more
I call them natural history I always was
interested in the deep questions of
existence why we here what's it all
about
what is life where does it come from and
so on
most of my but well I think well but one
of my books has been about evolution
probably for that reason my final job
was Charles Simoni professor of the
public understanding of science and so I
have an interest in science education
and I have an envious interest in
naturalism atheism if you ask me what
would make me change my mind I would
like to be able to say that it would be
possible to change my mind about
naturalism itself the problem is I have
a hard time imagining what anything but
naturalism would look like and
presumably the opposite of naturalism is
super naturalism
how could you even conceive of
demonstrating supernaturalism and so I
although I lay that out as being a thing
that I would like to be able to say I
could change my mind about I I can't on
the face of it imagine what that change
of mine would would look like because
the very word supernaturalism seems to
me to be incoherent and and actually
meaningless only because Oprah was
broad-minded open my do scientists are
supposed to be ready and willing to
change their minds if new evidence comes
in what I'm saying that I cannot imagine
what evidence for supernaturalism could
possibly look like well that's obviously
the
that if you could sequence the back of a
nucleotide sequence engine said
translation was sure I made this yeah
yeah I mean I mean that that's that one
that's the obvious one and and and I've
even written about about that but the
the problem with that is it's far far
more probable to be a hoax not other
hope I mean Craig Venters genome in his
bacterium actually says this was made by
see Venter and if not by anyone on it on
earth I mean it's I mean it seems to me
that quick and Ogle's that speculation
about directed panspermia and therefore
a signature from outer space is far more
probable than anything supernatural
because supernatural we like what could
it mean
you